hi I'm Jason Harris I work in the front
end and I'll be talking about the native
Wolfram player for iOS
so today I'm gonna be talking about the
native Wolfram CDF player for iOS and
since that's a bit of a mouthful just
sort of say player for iPad I'm sure the
the marketing people will get annoyed at
me but I'm gonna do that anyways so in
this talk I'm going to just zip quickly
through some of the capabilities of the
native Wolfram CDF player for iOS and so
you know you'll see how to actually
drive it and during this we'll take a
look at I'll demonstrate how to view and
interact with your files on an iPad or
iPhone how to get them onto your device
either through Wolfram cloud through
websites emails Google Drive Dropbox
iCloud sideloading and and and various
other things and so once i've showin
actually how to actually drive the
player on iOS i'll talk a bit about the
where we've come from the origins and
and of course the implications of this
and i'll just say i'm i'm presenting
this on an ipad here this is a dual-core
a 9x and what are what are the
implications of this whole new core that
we've got which is the exciting bit for
us here in the development for the
future and then from there i'll progress
on to persistence some topics more
advanced topics loading local packages
cloud storages and put this all together
in an example of peer to peer lending
and if i can get some time i'll get Nick
up here to talk about CDF kit okay
so let's actually then talk a little bit
about the player here so the wolfram
player for iOS is version the same as
the kernel so the kernel is at eleven
point three word eleven point three when
the kernel jumps to 12 a couple weeks
after we'll hopefully something on that
kind of timeframe will release of
version twelve the app itself is
entirely standalone and it's entirely
native it has a full local wolfram
engine here we've got a Mathematica
kernel running on this iPad we can use
it on a plane you don't need a an
internet connection the app itself it's
available it's free on the App Store and
the free app will open any notebook or
CDF document you can put anything on it
and read it and look at it you know also
additionally if it's signed by an
enterprise Enterprise CDF or it's signed
by us and demonstrations then you can
interact with with all the various
dynamics and interactive elements of the
notebook and of course this is maybe you
know your chemistry professor you
produce a notebook you
to all your students and the students to
interact with them manipulates and so on
in the document there's a one time
unlock thei of you know ten dollars in
the US App Store or something similar in
your local country app store and so this
ability is makes it sort of closer to
player pro that you can open any sort of
notebook and evaluate the dynamics once
you've unlocked it okay so let's just go
quickly zipping through some of the
capabilities of the native player here
so here I'm on my device I'm gonna open
I'm gonna go to a different notebook
here I'm just going to open this
typesetting notebook here and so here in
this typesetting notebook we see you
know some text some superscript a
fraction box you know square root box
some equation there some operators some
stretchable characters template boxes
traditional form some style boxes frame
boxes of different styles here here we
see a grid box with all its glorious
spacers and dividers and framing sort of
options and and so on and you know we
see the complete characters here here's
the Greeks we have a rotation box
everything sort of works and all of our
2d typesetting boxes in terms of
graphics we here you know here's a
raster box here we see it and here's a
you know a graphic here with the
background we can change through this
dynamic we've got circles through circle
box arcs disk boxes wedges graphics
group boxes line boxes polygons boxes
and all of our 2d primitives work okay
and our 3d primitives in fact we can you
know move it around with my I'm using my
finger to move it around and it's
actually kind of nice if with two
fingers I can pan stuff around I can
zoom it out zoom it in and you know
rotate it it's possibly even the
controls are a little bit nicer than a
mouse on a desktop and you can you know
just flick it and toss the actual
graphic it's very smooth the same way
was here we've got a parametric plot 3d
since we implement all of the underlying
primitives of course all the charting
functions and everything will produce
you know graphics that all work and
here's just an example of some of the
various primitives underneath you know
cones and cuboids and cylinders and
geometric transformation box and
graphics complex 3d boxes and graphics
group boxes and line boxes and point
boxes and polygons 3d boxes and cereal
boxes and two boxes okay so that it
gives you a good taste of zipping
through that we've got all the graphics
capabilities built in okay onto controls
here we
a slider and you can't see my finger
because it's on top of the control but
we've got this nice tool tip up there
and and we do this as an affordance to
tablet users because I'm covering up
that control with my finger I can't see
where it is but we have this nice tool
tip on on top and if yeah and of course
it's linked with the dynamic here's the
dynamic we can change it you know false
and true that they're all linked up we
can you know put it at one with this
pop-up or - there's out of range
condition for the slider here's a button
that sets X to minus one I tap that I go
you know to the other extreme of the
range and you know move it back and so
on so buttons all work set our bars
which are Center boxes underneath they
work and here we can see the radio
buttons are working you know locators
work I'll talk about those in a second
color sliders move those around blue so
on Action menu boxes animators as we see
and I wasn't kidding when I said we're
zipping through so yeah so we're zipping
through that you know some animator
boxes here progress indicator boxes are
working slider 2d boxes are working you
know here we have a checkbox is turning
on the axis on and off here's some input
fields this the first one is not
continuous so as I type in a value it's
not updated in other words the
mathematic option continuous action is
false and this but we click out just
like on desktop and and it will change
the value or we hit return will change
the value we can go to a continuous
action and input field and you see as I
type it's continually updating there in
that particular value
here's tab you with setter bar here and
you see we can put that on the right I
guess and move the various values around
tap on them and so on and here if my
internet gods are with me they are I can
go off to click on a link here's this
particular example that Steven gave a
gothic window here which we'll come back
to in a second so that's all the that's
all for controls let's take a quick look
at manipulate now manipulate looks a
little different so normally in a
manipulate on a desktop would decorate
the manipulate here with with the
controls but we don't do that for two
reasons one is that we're space
conscious maybe we're on an iPhone or
iPad space is at a bit of a premium and
number two if we actually had the
controls there when I put my hand over
the top of that you know that that
control
I'd be covering the content as I move
the controls so I can't actually put the
controls on the actual content so I put
they're put down on this raft bar you
can just sort of see down down the
bottom and of course manipulates often
have more than one control here's a
manipulate with several controls down
here on the bottom and now if I scroll
that activate and manipulate off-screen
it deactivates as it should and here we
see another you know a graphic here and
we can go in and and manipulate it
change it around it's all nice fast and
smooth and fluid and we can turn around
and animate that and see it in all its
glory and so here's just a one final
example buried in this in this Bezier
curve there's just one control point and
so you know just like on desktop we can
manipulate anything at any part or any
sort of place of the expressions it's
all the same sort of stuff so how does
this all come together so iPads are
great devices for consuming stuff you
know sometimes people will use them to
create stuff but often it's a device for
consumption so this wall comes together
and I've got a book chapter here from
Eric Schultz he did this for Pearson and
we actually use this in debugging some
of the feature sets to make sure we had
complete sort of coverage for this but
this brings together some nice sort of
example and this is his chapter on line
integrals and so you know some student
would come and take a look at this and
you know move the curtain and go oh
that's how line integrals working and
stuff so you know it's kind of nice and
you know that see that you're the romani
and integration is so it's quite nice
and so the book chapter is a nice format
here and you know you see the the
various formulas you can you know all in
line typeset math it's quite zippy you
can scroll through the notebook you know
back and forth get to the various bits
so it's all kind of responsive so that's
that's the kind of typical use would
have vision among other uses okay so
that's quickly zipping through some of
the examples on on the sexual device so
let's actually go through and talk about
opening documents from anywhere so let's
go and get something not from this
device let's go over here and take a
look at my Wolfram cloud account which
have logged in to before and I can see
the various files on my cloud account
let's go to demonstrations here and so
this will load the notebook off of the
cloud account here's the radial engine
it's a nice example it's a four stroke
five cylinder engine here you can see
animating look at three cycles you know
change the number cylinders and so on so
that's that's loading off of my cloud
account I could go here and load off my
Dropbox there's an import files down the
bottom there and so click on Dropbox
here go to demonstrations take a look at
this system a couple differential
equations here we see this this
streamline we can click on this
manipulate and change the length of the
streamline in this in this vector space
given by these different equations and
we can of course change the equations of
the system so that's that's an example
loading off of Dropbox let's actually go
back now to the web here and take a look
at this example this gothic window that
Steven did in this keynote and we'll see
that downloaded device button I click on
that it'll come up and we can just open
that and the Wolfram player and that's
loading a file off of the web so and
here we click on this you know
demonstration go through and move all
the various sliders and bits and take a
look at it all all works okay so let's
go back here to on my device and talk
about the various other things so
there's email attachments I want show
some of the other things one I will show
a little bit later side loading and
airdrop they all they all work no I want
to point out in particular that that we
really are doing local computations here
this is a full Wolfram engine that's
embedded there's there's a Mathematica
here on this iPad and so this of course
gives us vastly improved interactivity
we don't need a network connection and I
have ultimate respect for Jana and John
pay seein and people on the web team but
of course they have to fight against the
vagaries of HTML on Chrome and doing
something else doing some crazy bits and
it's people want native applications
it's what they desire so it's fantastic
that we have this native application and
for other reasons which we'll talk about
in just a second so this this whole new
core which I'm about to talk about we
have targeted it for iOS first and so
we've done some iOS appropriate things
for instance our finger size touch
targets are always big enough you know
it's hard to sort of you know we don't
have buttons where you know I missed it
you can't click on it I've pinch to zoom
works as it should for any iPad
application that manipulate controls we
don't hide them with our hands and
there's some of these other things here
the touch screen control placement touch
position for instance so let me just
talk about a few of these so on the
desktop we've got Mouse position but of
course on an iPad we don't have a mouse
so we've got things called touch
position so as I touch with my finger
you can actually see dynamically all of
the various touches so we've built in a
number of things like this that are
appropriate for tablets another such
thing is this control graph that we
talked about here we have a vertical
slider the control type is a vertical
slider but we've placed it on the right
and so now as I move the slider on the
right we can see the various expansion
of this polynomial and so we can place
it on the top left or bottom and in
other places let me mention here's
slider you've seen this nice tooltip on
it there but here we've got a discreet
slider right down the bottom of this
page here and so let me just blow that
up so we can see it here's this discreet
slider and so as I move that it can only
take on the values one two and three and
so you'll note there's a sort of
translucent residual sort of slider
there that that's present and that's
it's it's quite nice because that's
where Mathematica the kernel actually
knows the actual value to be and so we
call this internally the ghost sort of
slider slider thumb and it was
interesting in the development we put it
in there at the beginning because we
thought well the version on the iPad was
going to be too slow and so people would
need to know where the actual sort of
slider is it turns out it's not the case
and this is a very it uses advanced
crypto hashing and Merkel trees and all
sorts of other cool techniques so it's
very fast and efficient but we've left
this in because it's such a nice
feedback mechanism and you know I can
even imagine this coming to the desktop
at some stage as well it's it's it's a
very nice feedback okay and onwards for
a locator in the same vein as I'm
covering that up with my thumb on here
on the screen and so we have this little
magnifier above and so I can know to put
it you know put this locator exactly
where I want to it some particular you
know root or something else like that
which is another affordance for this
desktop version that this iPad version
okay so let me talk about this this
whole new core so I've actually been on
this project for five years rob has been
on it for longer and so there's various
people on the team we've been out for a
while and so you might turn around and
sort of say with being shipping a
version I think for a year in a bit and
you might say wow it took you five years
to port the desktop front end to the
iPad you guys are kind of
slack well it turns out for various
reasons we had to actually build a
completely new front end Greenfield
rewrite and it's interesting of course
because Rob and I had been working on
the desktop for a very long time and so
we have the benefit of massive hindsight
we we know where all the skeletons are
in the front end so we could actually do
things a good bit differently and so
some of the advantages they're in here
this this the sumo controller it's
multi-threaded from the ground up and in
fact let me just show you it's got this
you know great modern internal
architecture one of the features this is
a separate bill that's dev build I'm
just going to open it here it's got this
feature called incomplete formatting
turned on and so as I as I open this
notebook all those very cells that it's
taking some time to open it's sort of
filling them in on the multiple threads
as they all go through and and it gets
down and it can it can open them and of
course this on the main desktop would
would lock up at each one of the dynamic
dynamic pauses it would freeze so I'll
just open that again so now you know
what to look for you can actually see
all the various threads the quick
threads are going through and then the
there they're pausing on the incomplete
bits and then they're getting filled in
later on so that gives you an example of
the true multi-threading sort of nature
of this version so it's it's fantastic
we're all very proud of it and it's got
some fantastic new modern features and
of course the desktop is fantastic it's
got all of these you know wonderful
features with it and so our challenge
moving forward of course is to unify
these things as we as we move to a
multi-threaded world okay so let's I'll
talk about some current limitations of
this particular version some some
limitations are imposed by Apple some
are imposed because this is a player and
some are imposed because we just haven't
done them so for instance the first one
parallel tools Apple imposes the fact
that we only live in a single process on
the iPad they say each app can only have
one it can only live in one kernel
process space and so of course we can't
launch multiple kernels on the iPad
Apple won't let us so we can't run
parallel tools and in fact to actually
quit the kernel that quit the kernel
step is going here and and just quitting
that application and it quits both the
frontend and the kernel so so we can't
have parallel tools and unless you use
SSH to
excess external kernels likewise
something imposed because it's a player
is we can't save the notebook players
you don't really save notebooks instead
to get persistence you need to go
through local symbols something that we
haven't got around to what we will is
notebook programming so I should move
some notebook reading a book right from
from some of the selections because we
don't handle those just yet but we're
working on it and other various complex
things like buttons we use method we use
the pre-emptive link at the moment so a
method queued won't work at the present
time but we will expand it and we will
add that and one other important thing I
should mention is Java of course this is
imposed by Apple and Apple says you know
we're not having that Java stuff on our
iPad it's all got to be native code so
we can't run Java on the iPad which
means in particular that we can't run
like database link so to get around that
you've got to actually use URL executor
URL fetch or cloud evaluate or something
sort of similar so how am i doing for
time there so okay so let me just
quickly talk about side loading here so
one of the other things that I would
hook up my machine to show you but to
also get files on you can do something
called side loading so this is opening
iTunes I'd click on my iPad I click on
file sharing I click on wool from player
and here I'd see the list of files on my
iPad and so I can drag and drop files on
there and so here you can sort of see
the talk that WTC 18 and also you can
see that simulate p2 p.m. which looks
suspiciously like a Mathematica package
and it is and so we'll put a Mathematica
package on our iPad so I'll just briefly
I'll show this this local symbol here
I'm gonna store that locally and there's
a bug right right here three four minute
but it's loaded that that that symbol
locally that 504 oh right there okay so
where does this package live well it
Lizza this notebook directory and that's
a hideous sort of string UUID for
sandboxing purposes but we can still
just append our package name to the end
of that and load it so I just click the
load package button which you saw B
before on the on the iPad and now I can
do some simulations and so here's that
that's the average return of the
portfolio of
five thousand dollars over 36 months on
these grades of peer-to-peer investments
and so you know the package is maybe 200
lines long it's not you know huge but
it's it's still significant and so we
can we can run local packages and
there's some comment here if you look at
the notebook later on you'll you'll see
something about sessions submit and some
of the other other stuff so I'm just
going to quickly mention the cloud you
can use Cloud Connect of course it's got
full full capabilities you might need to
offload some of them for instance for
Java purposes here we're incrementing
something we can store that into the
cloud and then we can load it from the
cloud as well and we can load packages
from the cloud here
I've already got the package loaded but
you can sort of see a simulation of the
various bits okay so um I talked about
Auto loading I could talk about
peer-to-peer lending but let me just
quickly zip over and put all of this
together and show you this application
so thanks I'll make sure it's quit you
see me quit the front-end and kernel
there I'm just going to load that up and
you'll see quickly it's loading loading
loaded you see this this thing here is
this you'll see the technique in the
notebook if you look at the details for
auto loading a package or something on
visualization and here we've got some
particular some grades of investments
and so will will be bottom-feeders and
go for the poor people that are taking
really risky investments the degrade
investments maybe and turn around and
run that so so here it'll be using local
persistence to actually store which
grades that are used so you'll see that
sort of technique in there and here one
of the other things that's recommendable
on an iPad sort of application is to
have sort of instant interactivity and
of course so we don't run the simulate
simulation for two minutes wait around
and then finally show something we want
to give some feedback you know quite
kind of quickly and of course with this
application that put it all together
you can you know go in here and change
the different grades of investments and
you know get it different get a
different annual return here coming out
it may be like a twelve point six or
twelve point four for these particular
grades okay so so I just wanted to lead
it off and I just wanted to get Nick to
quickly talk about the CDF kits so when
we've developed this we've got this
whole new core that we're talking about
and and of course Nick you want to come
up then so will I talk about this is how
well you plug into
here you have it right okay so in
summary it's a it's a full native player
for iOS with an embedded Wolfram engine
and this is just one incarnation of the
core we have it compiling on on the Mac
we have a compiling on various to
various degrees on Windows and Linux web
assembly and and the whole core the idea
of this was to be able to we could
target lots of different platforms so
it's exciting stuff we're continuing to
flesh out its functionality and
unification is the big issue of the day
of moving the both of the front ends
together okay
and so finally I just wanted to plug for
pars here he's gonna be talking a little
bit more probably a little bit slower
than I am on the Wolfram and a mobile
world bringing and talking about all of
these various the the are various
solutions of including the player on the
on the device okay thank you so I think
I even finished early so I've got time
for questions this must be a first